as I see the movie and I try to
interpret it how in an Mundi the hell on
Earth a man who know who will die who is
surrounded by The Killing all the time
then wants to find a rabbi to say kadish
for the dead body of a
boy
um it seems to me that's that's that's
an act of of you know that at least for
him this this this dead boy
is
sacred but if we don't if we don't look
into the the darkest part yeah then
there's no there's no way to to see any
light you know and that because now
we're as a civilization we're trying to
get away from the dark you know death
and and and the darkest things and
obviously this corporate internet things
are you know being pushed on us so that
we're we become just consumers of any
kind but we we we I think it's very
important that's why art is important is
the the only way to look into the dark
yes yes but say say say kadish is not a
secular value so I mean you wrote this
book on kadish what's the meaning of
kadish
um yeah uh let me Begin by saying that
this kadish in laslo's film was proof of
the man's Humanity that he had not been
dehumanized and the the the program of
the Nazis never in the whole
extermination camp never mind the zunder
Commandos who were the darkest the
darkest fate that ever befell anybody um
was to dehumanize the Jews and to Dej
judaize the Jews they were the same
thing MH and when this man insisted on
finding a kades for in those
circumstances that was a a a powerful
Act of resistance a real real proof that
he would not die a broken man cuz these
these people had no hope of living they
knew that they were not going to survive
the ksh there are examples we know of
cases of Jews who in The Ravines when
they were killed by the einan grouin
which is actually how my grandparents
were killed they were heard to be
staying kades for themselves before they
were shot kades is um
designed
to Elevate the mythology of Kadesh is
that when a Jew
dies uh his soul will be evaluated will
pass before a Divine tribunal if the
process takes a year it's based on a
Biblical verse not important takes a
year uh the Assumption the rabinal
assumption is that most people who die
are neither Saints nor villains because
both neither the Saints nor the villains
require this yearlong tribunal but the
rest of us Etc Kadesh is at at this
tribunal the tradition looks for ways to
show Merit upon the soul of the deceased
one of the ways this Merit is shown is
by the the arrival of the Dead the
deceased children to say this prayer men
and women because the assumption is that
you can see the parent and the child and
if the child is behaving in meritorious
ways then this is this is proof of the
of the Merit of the dead parent so that
the son or the child who comes to say
kades is not there as the lawyer as The
Advocate he's there as the evidence he's
there as the evidence and the idea being
that this will then a a good verdict
will be given and so on but this but and
by the way the word words of the Kadesh
that there's not a single word about
death in the whole in the whole Kadesh
it w it is a it is a structural element
of the Liturgy that became used to
commemorate the dead in the in the high
Middle Ages along the Rin land when
after the Crusades the massacres of the
Jews in the Crusades there were too many
orphans who needed to rep the idea was
if you led the prayers you showed Merit
but there only three prayers a day and
there were too many orphans and so the
idea was it was divised that the rabbis
took this minor structural unit which
goes back to the talmudic acmy in Iraq
in the 10th Century this minor
structural unit and said okay all you
children all you boys who are younger
than Bar Mitzvah or even people who we
just don't have enough room you can all
get up and say this prayer and help your
parent soul that was the idea and ever
since then because of its association
with the parent child relationship and
because of this very powerful myth of
the the the the tribunal and what you
can do to help your parents get into
heaven um it became a minor prayer that
had
disproportionate position emotionally
and culturally in in in in the Jewish
tradition